WITH THAT IN MIND THE QUESTIONS,
DR. HARRIS HAS THE QUESTION.
>> SECRETARY CASTRO, DO YOU
DETERMINE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
POURING INTO OUR COUNTRY TO BE A
NATIONAL CRISIS?
AND WHAT IS YOUR SOLUTION?
>> Julian: THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE QUESTION.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A CRISIS OF
LEADERSHIP.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT FOR A
SECOND, WHEN HE CAME INTO
OFFICE, DONALD TRUMP SAID THAT
HE WAS GOING TO SOLVE THIS AS HE
PUT IT THIS IMMIGRATION PROBLEM.
AND HE HAS COMPLETELY FAILED.
LAST MONTH, THERE WERE 140,000
PEOPLE THAT CAME TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
AND IN OUR NAME, LITTLE CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN SEPARATED FROM THEIR
MOTHERS.
PEOPLE RIGHT NOW, ABOUT 100
PEOPLE ARE IN THE 100-DEGREE
HEAT OF EL PASO, TEXAS, BEING
FENCED IN AND KEPT LIKE ANIMALS
TOGETHER WITHOUT A SHOWER OR TO
CHANGE CLOTHES FOR A WHOLE
MONTH.
THAT IS A FAILURE THAT THIS
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN ON THE ISSUE
OF IMMIGRATION.
SO I SAY THAT WE HAVE TRIED THIS
CRUELTY AND HIS MISTAKES.
THERE IS A BETTER WAY TO DO
THIS.
AND A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO, I
RELEASE MY PEOPLE FIRST
IMMIGRATION PLAN THAT SAYS,
NUMBER ONE, THAT WE NEED TO
TREAT PEOPLE WITH COMPASSION AND
WITH COMMON SENSE INSTEAD OF
CRUELTY.
THAT WE NEED TO -- [APPLAUSE]
-- WE NEED TO PUT THE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE
IN THE UNITED STATES AS LONG AS
SOMEBODY HASN'T COMMITTED A
SERIOUS CRIME ON A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP INCLUDING AIR
DREAMERS.
AND WE NEED TO INVEST IN
IMMIGRATION JUDICIARY IF THAT IS
INDEPENDENT AND HAS ENOUGH
JUDGES AND SUPPORT STAFF TO
ACTUALLY GO THROUGH ALL OF THE
CLAIMS FOR ASYLUM.
SO THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT WAITING
IN LIMBO YEARS UPON YEARS.
PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT THERE IN THE
COUNTRY ARE JUST WAITING.
WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB THAN
THAT.
AND MAYBE MOST IMPORTANTLY, WE
ACTUALLY NEED TO GET TO THE ROOT
CAUSE OF THIS ISSUE.
AND THE ROOT CAUSE OF THIS ISSUE
IS THAT IN PLACES LIKE HONDURAS,
GUATEMALA, EL SALVADOR, PEOPLE
CANNOT FIND SAFETY OR
OPPORTUNITY THEY ARE.
IN THEIR HOME COUNTRY.
AND SO THAT IS WHY A MOTHER
WOULD BRING HER 6-MONTH-OLD
INFANT MORE THAN A THOUSAND
MILES ON A DANGEROUS JOURNEY TO
THE SOUTHERN BORDER OF THE
UNITED STATES WITHOUT ANY
GUARANTEE OF GETTING INTO.
BECAUSE THEY ARE SO DESPERATE.
IT IS SO DANGEROUS.
SO I CALLED FOR THE EQUIVALENT
OF 20 -- 21ST CENTURY MARSHALL
PLAN BASED ON MUTUAL RESPECT AND
WORKING TOGETHER WITH THESE
COUNTRIES AND MEXICO SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN FIND THAT SAFETY AND
OPPORTUNITY THERE AND 140,000
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO COME TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER TO TRY TO FIND
IT HERE.
I BELIEVE THAT IS A SMARTER,
MORE EFFECTIVE AND MORE HUMANE
WAY TO APPROACH IMMIGRATION BAN
THE WAY WE HAVE DONE IT.
AND LET ME FINISH THIS ANSWER BY
STATING, SOME PEOPLE ASK ME, WHY
IN THE WORLD WAS THIS THE FIRST
POLICY PROPOSAL THAT YOU MADE?
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT IS
PERSONAL TO ME.
I GREW UP WITH A GRANDMOTHER WHO
CAME OVER HERE FROM THE
UNITED STATES WHEN SHE WAS SEVEN
YEARS OLD TO MEXICO WITH HER
LITTLE SISTER.
AND THEY CAME BECAUSE THEIR
PARENTS HAD DIED.
AND SHE ENDED UP ON THE WEST
SIDE OF SAN ANTONIO.
SHE RAISED MY MOM AS A SINGLE
PARENT.
SHE WAS BASICALLY LIKE A SECOND
MOTHER TO ME.
SHE CAME HERE LIKE A LOT OF
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS DID OR
MAYBE SOME OF YOU HAVE WITH
HARDLY ANYTHING.
AND THIS COUNTRY PROVIDED HER
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK HARD, TO
PROVIDE FOR HER DAUGHTER, TO SEE
HER DOCTOR TO BE THE FIRST TO
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND
THEN GO ON TO COLLEGE.
AND THEN AFTER SHE GOT TO THE
UNITED STATES, ONE OF HER
GRANDSONS, MY TWIN BROTHER IS
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESSMAN